I mean the media in New Zealand is is
nuts they just lied I mean they didn't
they didn't exaggerate they didn't just
exaggerate they didn't just extrapolate
they they actually lied
um they blurred my hand and pretended I
was doing a white power signal they they
whipped up I mean maybe there's no news
in in New Zealand who knows but they
whipped up a frenzy I was I was trending
in those areas and I was on the news
channels every single night with you
know serious politicians coming out and
lying about me and saying that I was a
really dangerous person and never
talking about really any of the issues
that the women want to talk about in
their countries just sort of saying that
I had these uh guilt by association uh
relationships with a variety of people
that I've never met never talked to I've
got nothing to do with uh and just
whipping people up into this frenzy it's
it's a sight to behold